on y met un portait la liberté vous avez
besoin sous voile à angie m'a apporté la
légèreté dont j'avais besoin à ce moment
là il ya un exemple que des voies
montantes de la frite avec les français
j'ai cette faveur hier je considère
solution c'est de prendre son temps mais
aujourd'hui je suis plus sur ce que sa
pudeur mais
hélas je me demande où est ce qu'il est
le pur de bébés ont troqué donc tu vois
[Musique]
là et franchement je me réveille mois
changera sera j'ai toujours perdu juge
vraiment pas bien
alors guillaume genton qui a beaucoup
travaillé à temps alors c'est quoi cette
histoire savoir c'est que les
producteurs ils ont une journée pour
faire un épisode de 52 minutes donc il
doit aller à l'essentiel parce que s'ils
mettent leur caméra et qui se passerait
en voilà et là en fait clairement il est
5 heures du matin c'est en fin de
journée et il en qui les épisodes donc
ils font une heure d'interview pour
quatre ou cinq épisodes donc ils vont à
l'essentiel ils sont crevés est
clairement oui leur dise quoi dire parce
que c'est les phrases dont ils ont
besoin dans le montage et en ce sens oui
on peut dire que c'est scénarisé mais
après nola faut se mettre à la place des
peuples libres c'est pas facile non si
vous mettez votre caméra et qui se passe
rien vous n'avez rien que des bribes de
la journée en fait le ton de sa la fin
ils ont vécu des séquences ils les font
débriefer sait qu'ils vont ils leur
donnent les les mots et lui signale mais
non à l'horizon mais maintenant ils vont
mettre une séquence qui a été tourné
d'après midi foncé nomme d'injil mais
bon je m'en foutais là franchement ils
te pas tort mais non mais non mais en
fait il tony lee thomas un truc dans la
journée après il faut le commenter il
fier il faut souligner ne pas dire sa
marge à même les trucs qui tourne ses
commandes et il disait qu'il est
candidat oui j'ai descendu d'un bris
pour forcer les gens même sur le
tournage c'est bien fait mais benjamin
un moment il faut être honnête père la
mine mentir tu n'y connais rien et télé
réalité oui c'est quelqu'un que j'ai
lancé en france abrutissant soyons les
émissions
comme toi on
te planter pas tant de passion que vous
mettez pas débrief c'est pas vrai c'est
pas bien de dire que marc est bon j'en à
venir je m'en fous je suis pas
d'internet dans ta mort et a fait part
en surf avait fait un temps que tu
manges voilà pourquoi tu crois plus
rétrécies c
là ça veut dire que les enfants d'école
dire je veux m'expliquer vous y
connaissez bien mais laissez moi finir
le nom vous dit des bêtises ça veut dire
que les punchline que nous adorions des
leçons cela fait sont décrits bien sûr
dit kwatsi suite d'accords sûr que je
parle mais bien sûr que oui tout est
truqué oui bah ça mais alors je vais
vous dire
we are est au numéro oui ou non
sur le joli nom sur des écoutes moi
bordel donc sur infos-eau star académie
accor tient pas c'est quand on dit pas
c'est au nom donc quand ils passés au
confessionnal pour être débriefés des
télés vécu effectivement la production
leur donner des punchs taille et leur
faisait résumé c'était truqué dit oui
alors il pas si tu veux te dis oui parce
que
en fait le débrief de la journée
effectivement la construction de la
quotidienne effectivement dit et par la
prod sur les discussions qu'ils ont
filmée évidemment que c'est ça alors
maintenant eu la dent les marseillais et
autres hélas est poussé à l'extrême de
qu'il est vivant il est il épouse dans
un sens et dans un autre beaucoup plus
mais dans l'altérité que francesca la
fête ou la mienne non c'est pas vrai le
débrief oui le problème c'est qu'on
donne la parole à benjamin alors que
benjamin il reconnaît plus rien parce
que ça fait 20 ans qu'il a pas fait
démissionner
mais c'est pas méchant c'est la
vérité
eh bien nous révéler tout ce n'est pas
tout les pas du tout est codé prévenant
d'un
tracé que toi c'était autant de sommets
n'guema non mais c'est pas dans
peut-être peut-être qu'elle a mais c'est
un compliment que je lui fais parce que
à l'époque c'était autant de sites voilà
c'est dit non alors qu'emi refaites le
mec le compliment à l'époque c'était
authentique avec toi c'était naturel est
réellement c'est beau il était beau dit
il était vêtu très ludique et ses
phrases n'ont pu arrêter de parler
maintenant ainsi canon mais et des
magnifiques et très drôle voilà
l'adorait il était riche très riche mais
étant des preuves avait plein de femmes
c'est bon je suis là par le monde
j'avais kenya n'a pas fini en fait oui
oui et c'est pour ça que maintenant pour
moi ce sont des comédiens mais c'est pas
une tare de très bons comédiens je les
trouve très très fort et moi je suis
déçu quand je vois les gens justement
leur dicter des choses parce que c'est
leur personnalité qu'on aime donc en
fait on n'aime pas les ca comme celle ci
lui comme ça avec tes ce que vous deviez
dire me sens oui c'est vrai bah oui
c'est bien sûr y ait beaucoup vous soyez
meilleur et la quête j'aime aussi bon
que vous êtes nuls c'est vrai oui et
francesca le rouge était la star à quel
moment la star ac et moi ce que je peux
dire c'est que j'ai l'impression parfois
c'était scénarisé mais effectivement il
se basait sur quelque chose qui s'était
passé voilà pas chez passé imaginons il
ya deux personnes qui se rapproche
loana dans la piscine
il ya écoutez il ya toute une théorie
autour du loft comme quoi les séquences
qui ont fait le succès de l'offre se
sont surpassés dans deux pays c'est vrai
qu'à chaque fois qu'il y avait voilà
comme une bible avec la bible ces deux
pays avaient l'héroïne qui avait une
fille cachée comme loana ah oui c'est
vrai que dans deux pays avaient une
scène dans la piscine comme chez nous
donc moi je vais dans d'autres moi aussi
j'ai vu des animateurs qui a aidé les
petits sauvages
et animer cette émission personnes
voulaient faire ouais c'est vrai une
balade donc j'étais moi j'étais très
content sarthe et d'oseille baïse et
ingrate et vous les coups y en a pas du
tout bala ahmed serri étaient boursiers
les foules
regardez sens s'il vous plaît et demi
j'avais les mains ou sur la table
merci j'ai vu il a remis sur la table ce
qu'il a vu que j'ai vu voilà me
geraldine mais le problème c'est que tu
te voilà face benji parce que tout a su
organiser tout est écrit tout est
orchestré essais et c'est d'ailleurs
pour charmant n'a mis que ça marche plus
à dire que les gens sont pas dupes de ça
comme des kelly moi ça me pose même
problème si on me dit que c'est des
acteurs et que c'est un premier baiser
de bien sûr on n'y a pas de souci mais
qu'on nous dise partie de la télé
réalité avec des prêts séquence avec ça
déclenche avec mais non elle est plus
faible produit et donc c'est pour ça que
les gens regardent plus est on voit que
c'est dur le jour où jerry springer a
dit que c'était des comédiens ça marche
encore mais je vous signale à le voir
parce que vous dire ça c'est intéressant
pour expliquer aux téléspectateurs c'est
un show aux états unis ou en fait
c'était laisser un talk show donc je
voulais de zuma s'est embrouillé voilà
il y avait la même chose sur rtl9
en fait à la fin ils vous mettent en
tout petit c'était des communes et
revoilà et en fait c'était le jerry
springer show aux états unis ça fait un
carton blanc des années qu'à un moment
il faut mixer des comédiens de sa série
et ça a très bien marché même après
considéré comme idée en fait c'est comme
une fiction voilages et benjamin voyez
c'est ça il faut l'expliquer parce que
jerry springer personne ne sait qui
c'est tom et jerry oui
pour étayer les propos de kelis makala
boire un coup de
genou et il était dans son capital
des propos c'est le lancement ça m'a
fait ça m'a mis dedans non mais à
l'arrivée c'était quand le love c'était
en 2000 et
2001 pas d'instagram pas twitter est
bien sûr influencé rien et qu'il y as
tout à fait raison aujourd'hui
maintenant ils vont dans ces émissions
là pour après faire de l'oseille en
postant ces choses existent et s'il y
avait plus de tirer plus de naturel
quand tu as fait la star ac' francesca
avait plus de naturel peut-être un peu
de manipulation mais beaucoup de
fraîcheur comme naturel et à moi quand
je regarde les programmes comme ça et à
0 et fraîcheur 06 réalité
tu vas bien qu'on les forme est même
d'un médicament je voulais j'ai compris
qu'il ya un tournant quand on est quand
on faisait six clubs en tête au bout
d'un moment les gens faisaient secret'
non pas pour le sur le programme le
nôtre mais pour aller dans les anges
après exact c'est lui l'audient casque
dont on vient chez vous parce que il est
vieux il est ringard maintenant ce
marché a cédé en surface est vrai quoi